una Guerra sin tregua los residentes del
edificio donde un misil Ruso impactó el
sábado regresaron en busca de noticias
de sus vecinos y familiares
caterina de 17 años sobrevivió al
impacto del misil bueno
[Música]
qué hacer empecé a llorar y a gritar
salimos al balcón y los socorristas no
se rescataron lentamente ni siquiera
tuvimos tiempo de recoger nuestras cosas
tomamos lo que pudimos
hoy volvió con su madre para buscar a
sus dos mascotas en los escombros
encontrarlas con vida es su esperanza
tras convencer a los rescatistas de
Ingresar a las ruinas encontraron a una
de ellas
pero no todos tuvieron la misma suerte
la gente simplemente los odia Cómo puede
morir gente por qué matan a la gente
Rusia reconoció los ataques con misiles
sin mencionar el edificio de apartamento
de nipro Ya que en repetidas ocasiones
ha negado los ataques contra civiles el
sábado Rusia disparó 33 misiles de los
cuales 21 fueron derribados según las
fuerzas armadas ucranianas hasta ahora
los rescatistas buscan a otras 30
personas que probablemente estaban en
sus casas al momento del impacto
ha pasado exactamente un día todavía no
han encontrado a mi madre cinco pisos se
derrumbaron desde arriba es triste
por cumplirse 11 meses del inicio de la
guerra Reino Unido envió tanques a
Ucrania el país Espera que la ayuda
Aunque parece Modesta pueda animar a
otros países occidentales a suministrar
más armamento